We're speaking with joey jackson. Double l. I e. Jackson normal. Ok. I came to australia. So i'm julie jackson.
And i came to australia in one thousand nine hundred seventy three. After the aquarius festival.
I heard about aquarius. When i was living in the himalayas in katmandu.
Writing long and passionate letters to my sweetheart who was in australia at the time. We had met in hong kong and.
I was taking a very long time to return to western civilization. I spent a year in kathmandu. Went to england and.
Whilst i was. I was in england he sent me to get to come to australia south. It was an offer i wasn't able to refuse.
I arrived in australia in august and. Came up to nimbin. About ten days later.
And my arrival in the stroller had been a little disappointing.
The love story wasn't quite the love story i thought it was and.
It was very obvious that we weren't going to live happily ever after. So when i was coming.
We were coming through from polling data having met my. Possible future in-laws. And came down to nimbin.
And it was on the road to ukiah that i was struck by this of the well knowing that this is where i was supposed to be
living this is where i was. Yes to be. The idea of nimbin and and. Aquarius. Was already very appealing to me.
I had quit my job in hong kong. I said. I very jet set a fashion designer. Living fully and fast. Around the world.
And i felt that i needed to make more. My life and having seen. What was happening in the world. I might believe.
There was another way of doing things the. Commercialism and selfishness.
That i experienced in on he didn't stick why i wasn't what i wanted to do.
So you know i was living in sydney and being a playwright wife. What i wanted to do either. So.
There was this knowledge that. That i had that nimbin was. I really should be but i had no idea how or.
What was going to happen i went back to sydney and. Somehow i met the right people and.
I ended up coming out to nimbin for the first time to build tribal meeting.
Which would have been about september i think. With a very beautiful man called a poet called will techie.
Who i don't know where he's in the world now. And i got the training and was hitching from.
Lismore to nimbin and was picked up by carolyn norman.
Who were to go on to be very important in my life and my children's lives. How was the midwife who set up.
Birth and beyond and. Norman. Apart now. Is a great healer. And there i was in. Nimbin.
And with nowhere to go nowhere to stay i didn't know anybody except for will who had his own. Own things to do.
And an intention to go to the first time to the trouble meeting. I had a job. By the way and.
To repay my voice to a sweet hat back. For my ticket. To strike.
And i never been in those days was very small was very warm and very friendly. And. Anybody new in town.
Was immediately. Now to simple. And immediately.
People would come and welcome you and talk to you and so on and it so happened that this beautiful blue eyed.
Doc i lashed. Young man. Sat down beside me and sat started talking to me. And introduced himself as mark.
And i said do you know where i can stay and he said oh well we've got a bass you could come
and stand the bells at old toby. So i'll tell bees from lord of the rings i think of something.
And all these wonderful names of places that were developed in those days and. As true romance would have it.
Mark who i mean named marcus. And i fell in love and. Had three babies and. Got married at some stage and.
Then parted at some stage and remained very good friends over the babies and. What is it. Humans to come and.
It's a very green. And rich and for candour you know it smells fertile.
Things grow over night you can sit and watch things grow and. The feeling in.
In the seventy's certainly within my generation was. I guess we were.
We obviously young and of child bearing age and there was a great. Hope. Great optimism.
For the future that we wanted to make things different and.
Part of making things different is creating the generation to carry that on. And a desire to do it differently.
Many many of us had had experience. Childhoods that were maybe not as helpful as could be that were.
Were pressured by materialism which we all benefited from. But there was that that.
Pendulum looking back now with the wisdom of age. You know there was that pendulum.
Of wanting to reject all of that materialism which we saw was leading us down a fairly devastating path.
As we experiencing now.
So yeah to to to make families to create and create a new society
and part of creating a new society is creating new life. And so and. Such a joyful process. I mean for me.
Having babies was one of the most amazing. Joyful. Experiences i've ever ever had in mind i i i. You know.
I love having babies. I love being pregnant. And and. And i love. The nurturing. You know it's. It was some.
It was something that.
That has always been part of my nature but it really came into its full when i had my babies and and.
Expressed itself in me. Looking after everybody else's babies too. And i became a witness. And.
Was an official witness and. I had three. Three babies long term for.
Thoughtful periods of time one for three months i think. I fed. Ruby. And my son.
I moved into the house with ruby's pants and and nursed her watched her mother was.
Was ill and and to what my own children with me. I had three. By then and. All told.
That the rough tally is around two hundred babies that i that i breastfed over the years.
It was it was natural it was a natural thing to do. Between the mothers who we were very close friends and.
If there was for me if there was a baby that was crying or a mama that was tired.
It was so easy and very simple for me to just nurse the baby and. Maybe take take that. Take it a baby for a night.
To give their mother a rest. People did the same thing for me too. It wasn't a one way street and.
It was part of the tribal feeling that we experienced in those days. And so now.
It's sort of seventeen eighteen years later. I miss seeing. Many of my. Mighty babies is. As i think of him. You know.
At dances and clubs and parties and. And seeing them growing up and even. I'm sort of a t.v. Granny now.
When the one of the children that i looked up to recently had a baby
and i don't know how many are they've all scattered to the four winds and.
In many cases but a lot of them is still around and they're that precious and beautiful young people
and i have very good connections with many of them still. Coming to you. And that's.
It was while that was one aspect of it. Yes the desire to do it differently. The desire for different experiences. The.
The the longing to move away from the.
The mechanical and impersonal and come to know that that giving birth is a natural thing it's not not.
Not an illness it didn't need to be hospitalized. I guess it was. It was a step further step beyond the.
The little boy a method that was already very popular in europe and. I think probably in australia.
In england the home birth was. It was it was a fairly normal sort of thing.
Two of my sisters were both born at home and i was present for the.
For those births and that with their pain and that their thirty's. So. You know that that.
Yeah that was one aspect of the humber. And the closeness and support.
Support network that was built up between the women. Was very important.
Not only was that this is they actually having a baby at home. Important but. But that the support afterwards which.
Which varied in some cases it was full on and. And wonderful and. And is in all of those things sometimes it.
Missed the mark and and. Wasn't perhaps as good as it could have been. But we you know.
We did beautiful things and it was you know. Again.
Those bonds that were set up in the eyes to those days are still very strong.
And as the children grew up and as we grew up as women you know as we grew up. And changed and.
Experiences changed our needs changed. You know. We developed in two to two women who wanted something else and.
I needed to grow and. The. We had the women's group. Which was a very strong and.
Dynamic and exciting time for a lot of us and. Was a shift in many many of the women's lives. Women.
I'm trying to remember. I'm dreadful on dates. It would have been. Late seventy's.
It would have been someone in the late in the seventy's it was you know was it in the late seventy's the women's group.
Started we we would surely met. In blue knob. Round blue knob area. There were.
I think there was other groups of women as well meeting and. In in the area.
The one that i was involved in met it playing up once a week. And there was probably. Up to about twelve women.
Coming together and. We would have. Have set. Id set. Agendas on some nights. Themes. Telling our story.
Exploring options discussing things it wasn't an incredibly angry sort of a group of women it was more. Of discovering.
Supportive. Nurturing. Raping women. You know this.
The ideas of women's groups being sort of bunches of hardened sort of.
Bitching about the men and things and it wasn't like that too. It was there was the odd bits of course.
But you know that having that are not just true. They became a tribal event because they weren't. Confined to the.
It's the best at home. Became a tribal event.
Because they were not confined to two medical personnel being present or the official personnel being present. No just.
Immediate family members. So at some births there would be. Maybe a dozen people around the place people to cook.
People to to look after other children people to look after the other people's children. And.
And general supporters there was. And people came and went. You know it was a long birth the people would be coming.
Coming and going and. There was a lot of interest you know. We. The birth and beyond. Group met. Every tuesday.
And there was. Prenatal classes and. And post natal classes and so on that and meetings of women to to support.
And fathers to the fathers because you know. You know.
We were very actively involved in the whole process and the caring of the children.
As well i think that that's something that.
It isn't isn't recognised enough i think that a lot of nimbin dads have done a very good job. You know it's.
It's perhaps a difficult one to sort of to to single out isn't it wonderful that men are involved in child rearing
but tradition is is such that. That men are not involved in child rearing. Women.
You know have traditionally done that
and sometimes it's been something we've kept to ourselves i know that for me that was probably an issue and.
And so yeah the menfolk have played a part. As well as being caught up in the more traditional roles of.
House building and. And so on and the women have also been involved vice versa in the house building and so on.
Was so it was. Oh that's just. Absolutely i mean. Although i was a home birth. Helper. Myself.
I had my three children in the hospital. The first one was because she was a breech baby. No she wasn't.
She was before the birth.
The first one was my first child was born in hospital because that home birth movement was very young at that stage
and i think only one baby had been born out in the area then.
And i didn't feel confident enough it was later on that i got involved. Really fully.
My second child was born in hospital because she was a breech baby.
And the third one there were other complications in his birth so they were.
They were all born in the hospital but it was a very very positive experience. Emily was the first baby. He baby.
To be born in in lismore base hospital. And they were very supportive. I mean we still i still had to go out.
Undergo some of the indignities like shaving and. In animals which don't even happen in normal births now.
But they allowed me to do a lot of the other things that i wanted and.
Even to the point of letting me take the center home which they.
They found that the placenta was wrapped up in an in a lovely purple plastic bag and.
And kept in the refrigeration till i went home. And they let me out the next day.
You know with a few sort of and worried looks. So from from that. To. When will was born. It was. It was beautiful.
You know it was just really beautiful. I had. Carolyn norman with me. I had another friend there. His father.
The birth was done in exactly the way that i wanted to to do it out. You know. I couldn't have asked for better.
In that sort of environment. And. And after the birth we were left alone and. He wasn't.
Whisked off to be bathed in measured in weight and faster on paper.
So i think that the the influence of the humbert movement in the hospitals has been has been good as you know
and there were some fears and difficult things but. I think it's been through and i think it's being pulled.
And in cairo. They have a birthing center which is. Is the next step.
From having a sit in between having a home birth and. And a hospital bed. So yeah it's been influential. And.
And i think that it. It. It. That positive and supportive. Generally. Approach that that. The hospital has.
Makes it easier for women who are perhaps in a risky. Group.
To to be it to feel comfortable about having their babies in the hospital.
You know it's water births and things like that.
I've not been present in water but i know a number of baby sort of been born in water births
and i've seen the movies and son. Seems wonderful. And. And hospitals around the place also provide that service to.
And and doctors are involved in it. I think that it's just. Off that. Now we. It's not just either.
Hospital or a dangerous bet at hamill's or sun you know have to think the the.
The options of if you were having the more options.
Recently there's been a backlash as we always experience and in change. And i believe that.
You know that the non-accredited midwives are not allowed to to to deliver babies at home and this is. I think a very.
Retrograde step. You know it was because you know as soon as you saw in you. Was tradition. I think.
I think it's again about that pendulum. It's about.
I think what had happened in the in the sixty's the fifty's and sixty's post-war was that had been that great swing.
To to fit to model. To materialism. To to getting away from from the the spirit in community.
And so it was a very very fast swing on the pendulum and and.
Sometimes you have to swing the pendulum right the other way. You know to to to throw all of that stuff away. So that.
Set to two then come back to some kind of balance to find out. To sort out what.
What is necessary in what isn't necessary to to to find out. You know. A balance and. And sure.
You know i think there was there was a. You know.
I would never want to be scrubbing and washing nappies in a in a in a copper. Again.
Even if i was young and starting at you know it was. It's. It was hard work and particularly for the women.
It was very very hard work and i think that we you know. The were there wasn't the time often.
To to do a lot of the things that would have been good to do. I mean. I would always. You know give over.
Housework in favor of playing with my children so i was good in a fairly chaotic has but.
When you have to chop the wood to cook the food. When you have to cut the water to do those things.
When you have to dig the garden to get there the food. It's it's very hard work.
And yet you don't need all the mod cons and things that are happening you don't need all that the fast foods
and things and that. The chemicals and. And so on that that are contributing to the destruction of the planet either.
So it's finding that balance. What are my fondest memories my fondest memories. Picnics.
Had wonderful picnics picnics and. Community gatherings. And the dances. We put on the birth and beyond. Wonderful.
The folk club. The coming together of the community. Very very special memories and. And the smells. The not. The rain.
When it's been sunny. Not the rain after it's rained for three months. And yet. That hope that the people.
And the coming together of the people and. The coming together of many different people. Many of the. The original.
Settlers the original. People who lived in the bay area very very dear friends of mine now. Who.
I probably see more than a lot of the other. That the people who've been through and been of the.
So many nimbin as a place for as a learning grant. As a wonderful. Learning ground a wonderful growing. Time.
And it's got its pains as well you know this been. This has been difficult time. Us. Punk.
There's been difficult times. You know that the survival. In the in the the eighties. You know.
And the growing apart of my. My husband and i and.
You know knowing that that this a daily life isn't going to to go on. I think maybe we.
Plays a lot as children to you know has to be paired with our children so there was a certain unreality. There.
That was very real in the dirt. And in the earth and in the being. But even now i think that.
I was saying to somebody today that the lifestyle that we have on the north coast here. Is very special. You know and.
It's not the why. A lot of the world lives. It's not the way that.
That even the people that i meet in my work life and. I think we need to bear that in mind as well. You know that.
There's a there's a lot of despair. And a lot of pain in the world and. We're very fortunate. On the north coast.
So i think you know and it was a little bitch i was you know.
So i think that that was naive it was an important part of the growing up.
Of nimbin i suppose an important part of the exploration. That i think nimbin. Is going through and was going through.
To everything has a duality. And so that that that. That childishness was part of the the oldness.
Of knowing that that things were not going right. The wisdom that things were not going right. So again. To swing.
To to that. Absolute simplicity.
Was it was an important part if it hadn't happened it wouldn't you wouldn't have gone the whole way it's like you've
got to push the age. And. And we'll do all of that.
With that so-called lack of responsibility i mean it's all a matter of perception really i mean.
I think perhaps it was a very responsible thing to do it's a very responsible thing to do to say hey now this.
This isn't going the right way we've got to stop. The this. Greed and destruction and.
Materialistic approach to things. We've got to find community again and get back to to the important things and.
It was very very idealistic but unless you have something that's very idealistic unless you shoot high.
You're not going to. You know going to you're not going to get very far. So.
So i think that it is it is important to to have that that. That openness and simplicity and. Call it naive ety and.
And with that then there's room to grow. And then there's room to grow up if you. If you. If you call it that.
I had to take responsibility and to see that. The shadow side of things. In bins got it shut aside now it's.
Acceptance has. Has has on one side has led to abuse people who abuse that acceptance. It's it's. Dropping of modern.
Modernity and mod cons has led to to a lot of people getting very tired and a lot of people having to live.
Very hard lives. The the. Rejecting. Of the sort of. Work unpaid work for. Full on supporting that.
Capitalistic and materialistic society that. That was part of that has led to too.
Perhaps an inability to to see to see other options for doing things. And that in its intent is lead to.
In some cases lack of self-esteem and so on so forth. So. And at the same time we've got the rainbow. Power company.
We've got children who are flexible and. Broad thinking. And caring.
We've got a way of approaching things that is very different. The the. The home birth movement. The negotiation skills.
Community living. Checking it out you know we can people can write in theory.
About living in community and things where people in in the in bonaire in the north coast area. Because nimbin.
Isn't just nimbin it's the north coast and beyond and beyond and beyond.
So people are actually doing it and have been doing it for a long long time. You know.
Buddy phone's been going for a long time temple's been going for a long time. And so on and so forth. Did you think.
The things don't have to be. You know. Set in black and white. Oh no no no. I mean it's it's it's a business. For me.
There's absolutely no sense of failure. I think that. I mean.
If you if you take the approach to life which i have which is nothing is for no reason. That that. Every situation.
Has a positive side and a negative side. Every cloud has a silver. So you know that the. The growing of nimbin that.
The developing of nimbin the moving on from from the. The original aquarius. Dream is perfect. You know it's.
There is there is pain. And there is. There is some some really negative things that could be focused on.
And they're there. And there are the positive. If you see it on a long tim basis if you see it in a in.
In the continuum of ages. It's just a minute little thing. You know. And the effects of it. Are huge. And so if you.
You know. I refuse to get caught up in any. Breast beating and. Thanks to about it. You know it's. It is what is and.
And it's growing and. People are still talking about it. It's.
People are still talking about aquarius twenty years on that's you know. And people keep me. You know.
Young people that still hold those will develop those ideals and and.
The older people who've been involved in aquarius. Delusion changes.
But once in a clarion call and you know i wasn't even there for the festival and you know.
What was what is the best samples. As well that they did that they had an ism of of nimbin. Is is still.